you
there might be some players who jump in
like really soon right now there's 91
players entered in this one this is the
hourly bullit
Arina and it appears i am going to be
paired up with mr. John Madden in Game
one and I'm already making mistake let's
turn into a gambit or I guess an
exchange Slav of sorts I didn't even see
that they moved that's not cool all
right you gonna go for that I'm gonna go
after your king that was your king
Knight you just gave up just drop that
pawn and I just weak in the diagonal
this is a horrible start
horrible chopping pawns man left and
right get their queen this is bad
I'm playing right now it's bad real bad
I have something sneaky they shoot a lot
of time which is nice I'm hitting f2 why
didn't they Castle I don't know
caveman-style this is not good not at
all King is exposed they dropped their
queen though it's exactly what I needed
a free queen oh it's a good thing I got
that Queen I was they were they felt bad
for me I think in that one they're like
I can't just take all his pawns I need
to give him his queen I need to give him
a queen that was ugliness I I made so
many bad moves in that one so many bad
moves mmm I guess we're gonna go in for
an end game huh let's fly let's run like
the wind blows Knights pretty good on f4
stops Bishop e6 which is a nice post how
symmetrical do you want this position to
being really how symmetrical to position
to positional man
where the tactics where are the tactics
I'll get a pig on the 7th and be content
with it maybe right here I'll take what
you go ahead I dare you do it
alright tricky night ending why not show
off your night skills uh-huh
there you go improve that King position
who's gonna win provoke some weaknesses
stop the knife from getting here grab
some space mmm let's go here really
locked position huh really lock position
oh I will take the free pieces man why
my opponents giving me free pieces not
playing anything good here I'm not
playing anything good I'm just uh my
opponents are giving me free stuff and
I'm taking it it's a very good strategy
your opponent gives you free material
take it back to tournament
I'm sure you're learning a lot right now
okay I'm gonna have to try that when my
opponent gives me free material take it
I don't even know how to start all right
throw the E and F pawn Adam all right
let's go with this fianchettoed fish up
let's focus on that d6 square coming at
me here I got an open H file that Knight
is a pest on g4 or even there
am I not winning this pawn I guess they
get the Jeep on at the end but my queen
should be pretty strong no hmm kind of
Miss that okay two pawns for the piece
they might shock vac or no not a fan
with home playing once again against mr.
John Madden giving pawns away and stuff
just to get a square for my pieces there
in a pin watch out for a tricky tricky
move no hmm let's take here there's
already tricks like that right I'll be
looking on the clock here rook up and
over and right here with the rook Bishop
check a block with the Queen Queen e6
rookie for Bishop could take the pawn
okay I got to go into a Speedy Gonzales
mode what is that about
that's my fancy way of saying time
burners pins forks all right mm-hmm
wild H pawn check rook check oh you
lucky dog you you're just you're just a
mouse player shame on you try to play
some good chess next time all right
let's get down to business here my
goodness this is only a 26 minute
tournament this guy play hope chess so
the hope chess master oh I guess this is
going to be a mouse slip Mouse live
variation I'm playing the budapest by
accident has that ever happened to you
when you want to play e6 and go into
nimzo-indian land are bogo Indian
and you play this instead okay we're
gonna run with it I'm gonna try to
attract that epon down let's just go
back all right we're almost there we're
almost there that pond back well done on
h2 this will be a good flight square
maybe I could have grabbed that pond
right and the bishop here and then here
nice diagonal let's see how the Queen
deals with that yes we're gonna take mmm
nice move
Oh a mouse slip it's a game of mouse
lips rook sea floor mmm let's snag that
pond what's that all about
just run away a big time edge here I
might drop that pond but who cares about
him right let's make sure I defend this
this sc7 pond most important here I
don't know they don't have any time back
to terman maybe I should research that
one right
hindsight is 20/20 all right we're up
there with I guess we'll go with the
Sicilian here 13 12 sneak in a fishing
pole I haven't forgot about that I don't
do it too often anymore but why not give
it a shot every now and then like g4 all
right we're gonna grab that pond and
still not lose sight of maybe this idea
of H okay I needed that night for the
fishing pulled up take shape so scratch
that
let's just develop Castle g6 of Queen h5
on a half-open file who's gonna argue
with that we can dark squares there are
all my pieces flying just yet there's no
night move with check that's a pin the
very least they have doubled F pawns now
we'll go in for that Queen takes yes no
I probably should have taken it the
Queen if they're gonna damage their King
side structure like that because now my
pieces could try to drift over towards
their Kings side and bring the pain you
know open diagonal Bishop b7 open up the
diagonal get opposite their Queen
they don't have any time so grab on f4
let's do that as a start another Queen
and Bishop I know any time time burner
just for fun Queen takes h2 all right
seven leader had he just had his speed
bump here he's at 17 but he doesn't have
the fire he need the fire 16 minutes all
right
this is Repco we've played before
hunting down my light square bishop
all right let's push that night around
see if he has a good next home all right
there Queens gonna feel a little
uncomfortable now get out there night
you're no good you're no good let's
tickle their jeep on right there let's
see how they react tickle tickle
oh all right I'm gonna damage my
structure I guess huh I don't know if I
want to take save that pawn he's
important it's their queen up - man get
out of there bishop I should really take
no good here they're gonna track down
that F pawn yikes
am I gonna drop upon
let's just throw a check-in out here I
maintain that upon think he's important
really I just gave him a connected past
pon don't know if that was a good idea
hmm
don't know how to assess this ending
don't think I could win
I could lose though if I'm not playing
it right now it's a draw
am i inside the box
maybe you think so I'm not time burners
cannot I need to keep that pawn any of
us can offer a job hey man I'll play
this game I will definitely play this
game I'm not wasting time offering a
draw oh I don't have any sneaky pre
moves maybe I do okay it's a drop I was
a good offer the draw I had the time
image all right that's a drum 20 19 18
18 17 all right Antonio let's go with
Knight f3 yeah that was no good they got
that battery going on that lung that
light square diagonal this guy gonna
move I could use a quick win oh he moved
he moved all right oh you had to go
there right then all right then in there
let's break these guys up kick that
night out of there go away here I guess
how to make some more premiums happen
huh gotta go faster we can their dog you
know move pond I want to get on this
diagonal
hmm all right Bishop h6 I guess f8 mate
sneaking in sneaky Queen g7 stake pin no
they could just take care yeah why not
hey I'm giving them free pawns why
wouldn't they take it oh but they're
giving me free free pieces now man can I
get that pawn I definitely can
all right goodness this is just a
tournament of where I give my opponent
free pawns and then they just return the
favor
now can I win with the two bishops let's
see if you could mate let's check now
stalemates Bishop's the deadly bishops
that's mate 24 22 21 20 when are you
gonna pull ahead here how many players
are in this one only 11 minutes
remaining nimzo-indian huh this is how
you try to win games fast no you got to
change it up all right I'm gonna bring
something different in the next game try
and end the game before my opponents
clock ends before they run out of time
be 5 and then get my knight here maybe
get this move in first now first things
first stop c5 and then worry about b4
okay this is this is really good now
Queen trade this is an excellent ending
pre-move you've control over that pawn
stop c5 good control now here get a good
pre
move in now probably should have done
this okay this is still not bad sake
with the pond no the rook I have a five
defended they missed that gonna resign
it's just trade King position King
position King position rip position try
that sometime try that sometime
gonna get a mate soon you have a past
pun or you know you're gonna push that
past pond or what they resigned back
determine twenty five twenty four twenty
two three back ten minutes remain
so you don't get paired up with 186 nice
alrighty
rut all right let's try this
who gonna go for a quick kill against
their king now they're Knights not on f3
anymore it could be dangerous they're
feeling the pain maybe Knight g4 caveman
a little variety on on the fishing pole
I think so watch out for each two he's
booking he's booking it's a trap though
it's a trap
don't take that h-bond he is poison when
the King runs away then you take because
then you're on the night let's open up
the F file we need more fuel bring the
fuel towards the king look at this get
out of there night
now he's pinned well he's been pinned
just realizing that right now alright
I'll take him get run away here not
afraid should I be um are you gonna
start
cashing in on this attack against their
king maybe I'm losing my rook now yeah I
am okay this wasn't so great uh yeah not
a good idea here all right so I should
still have it this pawn is a beast no
its checks push here should be working
out getting a clean threatening mate
right here what's that
oh just throwing in the kitchen sink
throwing in the kitchen sink high for a
second I thought I lost that time they
lost that time oh yeah I shouldn't have
allowed there uh I should have dropped
my rook okay try not to drop you're up
next time I guess another Sicilian let's
open it up all right let's push this on
right down all right let's see how you
deal with that let's get rid of their
strong Bishop it's offset him all right
and make sure that Knight doesn't cause
you any problems I want to keep control
over b4 give me the B file get out there
let's take that now you've gone far
enough
they're Knights gonna weasel in there
let's go here where's their Bishop gonna
develop anybody know are they going yes
yes they felt the pain the space invader
pain the space invader pain let's not
let any accidents happen on g2 that's
where you belong Knight get there be a
pain oh you canceled that way
let's throw the wild beep on it yeah hmm
I don't like this pressure that you're
putting on me here they could take the
pawn
yikes let's grab him man my knight
defend Queen it's important you defend
oh man not liking this yeah I got to
watch over for rook checks and stuff
crawling up into a ball I love seeing
that that's exactly what I wanted to see
their trades not even up a lot of
material okay I'm up time that's about
it time burners free rook yeah let's
just take their note I'm back to
chairman man man 32 this guy is a bunch
of speed bumps but he's still in first
33 five minutes left I got to get that
guy he's on fire
we didn't get paired up we got to get
paired up all right let's go here no
matter what
keep pushing get your bishop there I was
gonna take their next all right let's
put pressure here I think I'm gonna line
up a sack on this square mm oh I could
get that pawn and I could take if Bishop
e3 with check there
let's take with check and what's mmm
watch out for that night it's a
dangerous man f6 fh5 Queen trade scheme
isn't ending anytime soon oh let's do it
anyway
get a knight trade if takes maybe f5 was
better now this is correct I want I want
the F file to open up
didn't move let's go here Queen f6
hitting the bishop chase the Queen away
let's take their with check no go here
lining up mates clean here rook up -
they moved I didn't realize all right
abort let's just go with the let's go
with what's easy here ooh you're close
to getting mated I hope you realize and
I'm talking about myself yeah I was I
felt like I was really close to getting
mated there we were even DUP yay 34
finally with plenty of time remaining
well done you're in first by a hair on
tiebreaks
get your C pawn working there c7 point
is sensitive hit it hit it again on c7
maybe the bishop
oh the think tank I love seeing that
there in the think tank okay
return Bishop f3 he's a super defender a
super defender don't know if that was a
good idea they're gonna throw a rock on
the D file there's no good discoveries
though confident confident of that let's
just make sure nothing dangerous happens
there we go defense c5 some nice easy
moves in there let's come over here
Knight takes B is probably working now
maybe I'd go with the Queen sac alright
Bishop c4
I've thrown the check go here they're
low on time low on time no no no no no
no that would have been bad I've been
the only way to lose the only way to
lose no time
determine when we have 38:38 oh man a
minute 36 he's got me on tiebreaks 203
you're in here
Oh is he please playing right now come
on car pops of4 why did I decided to
play the birds opening yeah I need a
quick win can I do this I have a night
discovery all right what's the material
con I lost track just then okay check
let's throw the night in there that's a
pawn they'll take them trades you ready
to drop a piece he Ike's here grab
another pawn hit the rook get here man
this is where you belong have that here
hang hang on to him its technical games
man these technical games No
all right the tournament's gonna be over
before this game yeah and I just dropped
that pawn they didn't take it though all
right um you know I should just focus on
trying to win because that's what you're
supposed to do right you're supposed to
try to win I've checked there yeah this
isn't working out so well tournament is
over
okay I'm actually slowly improving that
I know how to win get my king over here
who cares about that pawn at this point
track these guys down Oh actually I'm
seeing that I'm in the lead
cuz I have fire yes I love fire I love
having the fire the fire gives you
tiebreak tiebreak stuff gives you tie
break stuff
that's exactly how everyone was seeing
it yes he has tight break stuff back to
tournament the fire yes way to go I
guess he he won there he need the fire
at the end man 38 38 37 final standings
but fire power
I have fire power
oh man okay 38 38 37 29 28 28 28 28
alright there were 205 of you in that
one let's see
everybody who took part page 2 3 4 going
fast like to show everyone who competed
in this 20 pages players 21 almost there
we're getting there and that's gonna do
it alright that was a massive turn out
well maybe no I don't know about that
but uh I don't know not too many times
two hundred-plus
in there to the 205 of you that took
part in that good games oh that was a
close one
alright
you